thank you
foreign
that's what we're seeing currently
that's what we've been dealing with for
the past couple of weeks a manufactured
crisis
and don't take our word for it just
listen to members of the House Freedom
caucus they've been very honest about
this
and are now openly they're saying the
quiet thing out loud referring to the
full faith and credit of the United
States as a hostage
but I I do want to be clear here
averting default is the responsibility
of every single member of Congress
think about what's at stake here and
that's what we've been doing we've been
laying out for weeks for months what is
at stake
a default would have catastrophic
impacts in every single part of this
country whether you're in a red state or
in a blue state
it doesn't matter every single part of
the country we're talking about millions
of jobs lost devastated retirement
counts and a recession
we've also heard some House Republicans
refer to preventing default as the only
concession they are willing to make
but preventing a catastrophic default is
not a concession
it's their job
period
and let's be clear about what
Republicans are demanding in exchange
for doing their job and preventing a
default
earlier this year they put forward an
extreme package of devastating cuts that
would slash supporting support for
Education law enforcement food
assistance the list goes on and on and
on and on
by what what now would be about 30
percent
that is not at all what the American
people want that is not what they
deserve that is not what they're asking
for
and the president has made clear he's
made this very clear that that is not
happening on his watch
House Republicans have said we need to
make these Cuts in the name of fiscal
responsibility and deficit reduction
but that's not what this is about
that's never been what this is about for
them
because even as they fight to gut
investments in hard-working families
they want to turn around and protect tax
breaks skewed to the wealthy and
corporations
and guess what just last week the
nonpartisan Congressional budget office
said those tax cuts would add 3.5
trillion dollars to the debt over the
next decade
and don't forget don't forget this it
was under President Trump
the last president not President Biden
that America's debt increased by 40
percent
Again by 40 percent under the last
president
during President Biden's first two years
in office he cut the deficit by 1.7
trillion dollars now folks that's a
record
and in March he released a plan that
would reduce the deficit by another
nearly three trillion dollars over 10
years
not by slashing programs hard-working
families can count on but by cutting
wasteful spending on special interest
and by asking the wealthy and big
corporations to begin paying their fair
share including closing loopholes
those are the contrasting Vision that
these negotiations started with that's
where we began with the negotiations
now look the president and the speaker
have agreed they both have said this
they both have said they agreed that
default is not an option it is off the
table the speaker himself has publicly
acknowledged that for any agreement to
pass the house the Senate and to reach
the desk of the president it's going to
need support from Democrats that is the
reality that we're in
the president's team will continue to
negotiate in good faith to reach a
reasonable bipartisan budget agreement
that's what the president and the
speaker agreed to and that's what they
tasked their teams with reaching from
this outset
and that's the only the only way to move
forward here on behalf this is on behalf
of American families on behalf of the
American people
so
if I've left you with any doubt about
House Republicans priorities in just a
few hours all you got to do is check
yourself House Republicans vote on a
resolution to block President Biden's
plan to provide up to twenty thousand
dollars in student debt relief to
borrowers who uh most of whom make less
than seventy five thousand dollars a
year the president's plan is a good one
it's a popular one and it will help
prevent borrowers from default when loan
payments restart this summer
the choice House Republicans make today
will send a clear message to their
constituents let's take a look
will Marjorie Taylor green who had a
hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars of her own business loans
forgiven vote to deny debt relief to the
92 000 student bars she represents
will will representative Vern Buchanan
who had over 2.3 million dollars of
business loans forgiven vote to deny
student debt relief for a 95 000 of his
own constituents
to the more than 40 million eligible
student borrowers who are eagerly
waiting to learn about the fate of their
debt relief I urge you to tune in
today's vote into today's vote to watch
which Republican
lawmakers shamelessly vote against debt
relief for you
after having their own
loans forgiven
and know this President Biden won't
stand for it he will not stand for it
and he will veto this bill
because let's be clear this is not about
cutting wasteful spending for
republicans and it never has been the
same Republican lawmakers objecting to
student debt relief are refusing are
refusing to cut billions of dollars in
handouts to Big Oil they even had their
own loans forgiven as I just laid out
and you just saw
on the chart to my left here
meanwhile President Biden has reduced
the deficit 1.7 trillion dollars and put
forward a plan to cut wasteful spending
and to end the deficit by another three
trillion dollars over the next decade
and finally I want to say a few words
about a somber occasion that we are
marking today here at the White House
one year ago
the president was in in his office on
Air Force One
returning from an official trip to Asia
when he saw breaking news of a school
shooting in Uvalde Texas
like millions of Americans he was
horrified and heartbroken
yet again our nation had lost innocent
young children
and teachers in a deep in a deadly act
of gun violence at school
when the president landed back at the
White House that evening
he was briefed in the Oval Office and
addressed the nation from the Roosevelt
room
he grieved for the families in Uvalde
and called on Congress to act
the following Sunday the president and
the first lady traveled to Uvalde to
visit a memorial outside Robb Elementary
attend a mass with grieving members of
the community
and spend time with the families who
lost loved ones in the attack
the shooting in Uvalde had also come 10
days after the devastating mass shooting
in Buffalo
and together these attacks became a
catalyst for the passage of the
bipartisan safer communities act in
Congress
since then in addition to signing the
most significant gun legislation in 30
years the president has continued to
implement dozens two dozen
executive actions to help reduce gun
violence and keep weapons of war out of
dangerous hands but he has continued to
say
that it's not enough
it is not enough
and he's continued to call on Congress
to take action
this afternoon President Biden and Dr
Biden the first lady will mark one year
since that tragic day in Uvalde
which stole the lives of 19 children and
two teachers and injured 17 others
the president will remember those lost
prayer lost
with prayer you'll pray for the
survivors the children the First
Responders and community members
who will bear the trauma and scars from
that day for the rest of their lives
and he will reiterate this call for
republicans in Congress to help stop
the epidemic of gun violence that has
become the number one killer
of our kids in America
from Universal background checks to
requiring safe storage of guns to ending
immunity from liability for gun
manufacturers to Banning assault weapons
and high-capacity magazines we need
Congress to enact Common Sense policies
that Americans support
Uvalde
is a tragic reminder
of the urgency
to pass gun safety legislation
with that Darlene please take it away
thank you a couple of questions on the
debt limits uh there's a there was a
change of venue today for the talks the
negotiators are here can you uh tell us
if the president perhaps might have
dropped in
um
why are the negotiators meeting here
versus Capitol Hill where they've been
meeting since the beginning so as you
know as you just stated Darlene they've
been meeting for since the beginning uh
at on Capitol Hill we truly appreciate
the speaker's Hospitality for those
important negotiation budget
negotiations and we tell we just felt it
was time for a change I wouldn't read
too much into the change of venue but we
are glad to be hosting the negotiators
here just to add a little bit more uh
color it's happening in the OMB offices
at EOB which is just on the other side
of West exec and it started around noon
today and it's still continuing
you saying whether
any contingencies are in place or being
made for the president's travel in the
event of the default the White House had
previously announced that he's traveling
to Colorado on June 1st which could be
default day
um
to to speak at the commencement for the
U.S Air Force Academy as you just stated
who the plan is for the president on
June 1st to go speak to the graduates at
U.S Air Force which happens to be in
Colorado and so the president as the
commander-in-chief is looking forward to
certainly giving that commencement look
our job and our focus and what we're
going to try to do and and that's what
the negotiators have been doing for
these past several of meetings is to
certainly to continue to work on this
budget negotiations and to avoid default
the president has been very clear
Congress needs to act we need to avoid
default and so we are going to work very
hard to make sure that that we don't get
to that X date and quick one uh has
there been any uh Mr President reached
out to the governor of Guam with the
typhoon approaching or inching over the
island there so I don't have any calls
to read out just a couple of things the
president has been briefed on the
typhoon and is is continuing we're going
to continue to uh to look at the impact
uh that the typhoon will will certainly
have in Guam on Monday night the
president approved an emergency
declaration for Guam and ordered federal
assistance to supplement territory and
local response federal agencies
including FEMA Coast Guard U.S Army
Corps of Engineers and the National
Guard have been deployed and are
coordinating response effort the White
House is in close contact with the
government of Guam and has offered as
much support as needed to respond to
this uh to this tragic to this tragic
major storm
we'll practice
on on the next day there will still be
money left what is the rate of the cash
flow and where will the money be
prioritized
um whether it's Medicaid checks Social
Security checks what happens on that day
so as I've said uh look
um look that's not the as you uh speak
to prize priority prioritization uh that
is not the plan it is a a recipe for
economic catastrophe it would throw the
economy into chaos so just want to be
really clear about this the uh the
secretary treasury said and has said
this as well that prioritization is
effectively a default uh Stephen Stephen
um munchkin munchkin said and I quote
that doesn't make sense the government
should honor all of its obligations and
the debt limits should be raised Jack
Lew I think prioritization is just
default by another name Timothy Geithner
prioritization is unworkable harmful and
the world would recognize it as a first
ever failure by United States to meet
its commitment the only way to avoid
this kind of economic disaster is for
Congress to do its job it's for Congress
to act to prevent default and that's
going to be our focus at this time and I
hear that but I think a lot of Americans
don't understand what's going to happen
practically can you help us understand
that so look here's the thing this is
why we have said this is would be
catastrophic to our economy if there is
a default we've been very clear we've
laid out what could potentially happen
remember this would be our first ever
default if it were to happen we were
going to do everything that we can to
avoid this that's why we've been asking
for Congress to act but a couple of
things that we would that this would
lead to it would wipe out millions of
jobs up to 8 million jobs it would
trigger a recession it would devastate
retirement accounts it would increase
costs it would damage our International
reputation this is what could
potentially happen if we divul default
again we are not a deadbeat Nation
that's what the president has said we
have been able to pay our debts since
1960 we did that 78 times so and that's
just one part of what could happen the
other part that what could happen too is
we could see the the gains that we have
made these last two years under this
president when you think about 12.7
million jobs that could be God when you
think about unemployment rate at the
lows at one of the lows that we have
seen 3.4 percent that could hurt that
the manufacturing Boom the 80 000 new
jobs that we were able to create with
manufacturing jobs that could be gone
the 1.7 trillion dollars a deficit that
the president was able to do the first
two years a record that could be all
gone so that is what's at stake and I
believe we believe the American American
people understand that and so we're
going to do everything that we can to to
make sure that that doesn't happen
more on the negotiations McCarthy has
been very clear what Republicans are
asking for the White House has made
clear where President Biden is willing
to meet them halfway but what
concessions are the white house trying
to get in this deal in other words what
are you going to get out of this deal
other than raising the debt ceiling so
look a couple of things and I've said
this I think I said this yesterday the
president said this on Sunday not
certainly not going to negotiate from
here but I'll lay out a couple of things
that the president has been very clear
we put forward a proposal that cuts
spending by more than one trillion
dollars that's on top of what the
president put in his Budget on March 9th
which is uh which is a three trillion
dollar cut in deficit over 10 years and
the president has made clear that he and
Congressional Democrats cannot support
devastating cuts that would slash in Law
Enforcement Education and food
assistance so we've been very clear on
those pieces we've said this over and
over again I'm just not going to get
into specifics from here beyond what the
president not laid out on Sunday thank
you cream Republican negotiators I've
been talking a lot on the hill it's one
of the concerns that they've raised is
that the White House negotiators have
not been empowered by the White House
they say young and richetti are talented
and that they work hard but felt that
they were being hand strung by the White
House can you speak to that and whether
the White House negotiators are being
empowered by the White House they're
absolutely empowered this this is a team
that the president selected himself
these are long-term advisors a long time
I should say advisors to the president
if you think about Steve richetti if you
think about Louisa who have been around
him since he's been Senator and you
think about Shalonda Shalonda who has
Hash a lot of young the OMB director who
has had an impressive history working on
the hill and also here working for the
president these are talented extremely
extremely talented and experienced
experienced individuals who are now part
of this negotiation team for the
president on the budget and the
president trusts them and and really uh
you know believes that they can get the
work done and so look negotiations the
way that we see them remain productive
as you know they are meeting right now
at OMB uh with uh with the with house
negotiators uh there are always going to
be disagreements right and I said this
yesterday I kind of go went into how
negotiations work they they it is a
democracy in action right we're not no
one is going to get everything that they
want that's something that when you
negotiate you have to understand and so
look the big and important thing is that
uh they are we are talking that's part
of negotiation is talking and the talk
and the talks continue and uh and we
believe that there isn't still an
opportunity here to get to a bipartisan
reasonable reasonable bipartisan
agreement that Republicans and Democrats
in the house and the Senate can move
forward with can I also ask you
um about the I mean essentially the lack
of a significant Market reaction to
these talks there are analysts uh out
there who who feel that a market
reaction could actually serve as kind of
a forcing mechanism to move the sides
closer together
my question is has the lack of a market
activity maybe hurt your efforts maybe
hurt the White House's bargaining
position negotiating position so I'll
say this I got to be very careful as
we're talking about the markets here I'm
not going to speak about the markets
reacting or moving that is not something
I'm going to do from here what I know
and what we believe is that the American
people they understand what's going on
they understand what's at stake and so
what we are going to do is focus on them
that is the most important thing here
making sure that American families get
what they need right to make the ends
meet as they think about as they think
about what is it that there is needed in
their household right having those
conversations those really important
conversations that many American
families have almost every month if some
some of them even more and so that is
our Focus we know we know I just I just
read out what could potentially happen
What could potentially happen if we
default millions of jobs you know
trigger a recession we can't allow that
to happen this is why we're continuing
to have these conversations why the
president has been very firm on how
Congress needs to do their job and deal
with the debt limit but isn't the lack
of a reaction a representative that that
Americans aren't as concerned as to the
things
I appreciate the question I'm just not
going to speak to to Market that is not
something I'm going to do from here from
this Podium and what I'm going to speak
to is what we're going to do what we
know would be catastrophic to our
economy what we catastrophic to American
families and that's why the president
has been very very clear on this he has
held the line on this for a couple of
months which is Congress needs to act we
need they need to deal with the debt
limit just like they have done 78 times
since 1960.
um just talking about what Republicans
have said about your negotiators can you
characterize how you guys feel about
congresswoman McHenry and Graves and how
they've been negotiating up to this
point look what I can say is that the
negotiations have been productive which
is what matters the conversations
continue which is what matters and the
focus is on what what the leaders said
themselves What speaker McCarthy and
what the president said as well which is
uh default is off the table we're going
to continue to negotiate in good faith
and if that is what occurs then we can
get to a bipartisan reasonable
reasonable negotiation or deal on a
budget on a budget deal and that's
what's important and so that's going to
be our Focus here where Republican
offers currently stand are there any
regrets about entering the negotiations
since they haven't seen to have moved
all that much from where they were
originally so we we believe they've been
productive That's What We believe We
believe the conversations these
negotiations remain productive and
that's the path that we're going to
continue on we believe that there's a
path here to move forward of course of
course there's going to be areas of
disagreement that's what negotiations
are all all about right that's why
there's that's why we're negotiating
here but look we believe that we can get
to a solution here we can get to a
bipartisan reasonable agreement that
again let's not forget this this
agreement has to get the support of
Democrats as well as Republicans in the
house and in the Senate
you just said repeatedly that you
thought that talks had been productive
but you also opened the briefing by
putting some House Republicans on blasts
that you put up on the screen so how
have talks been productive so look
um
we just laid out I just laid out the
facts that's all I've actually what I
did was lay out the facts that I've been
talking about and and highlighting for
the past several months
and I think it's always important to do
that I think it's always important when
I'm in front of you all and when we're
when I'm talking to the American people
for them to know exactly what's
happening and that's what I did now
are the talks productive yes we believe
that the negotiations the budget
negotiations that have been happening
are continue to be productive but at the
same time we I think it's important to
lay out the facts for the American
people as they are wondering and curious
about what is happening right here in
Washington DC what is the progress the
specific progress
I'm not going to get into specifics
about what's being discussed in these
negotiations we're going to give the
negotiators some space as we've been
saying to negotiate to have a discussion
to have a conversation we have been very
clear yes is there are are there areas
of disagreement absolutely which is what
negotiations are all about they're going
to we're moving in good faith having
those conversations in good faith and we
believe it's a path forward to get to
again that bipartisan a reasonable
budget agreement because that is what is
needed for it to actually move out of
the house and move out of the Senate
into the on the desk to the desk of the
president and then lastly on that point
June 1st just around corner does the
White House believe that it will have
the money to keep paying the United
States is bills beyond June 1st would it
be a day two days how long so look any
any specifics on the X date and what
that's going to look like post-ex day
that's something that the treasury
Department uh is is going to answer or
that's something that they're going to
look at not going to speak from that to
that from here what I can tell you is
our our focus is to avoid that our focus
is to give the negotiators some space so
continue to have this conversation to
continue to cut come to an agreement
that is bipartisan that can get out
again get out of the house get out of
the Senate and get to the president's
desk so he can sign it and that's going
to be our Focus right now
uh over the past day or so it seems like
there's been some really tough talk from
officials about
speaker McCarthy basically saying he's
talking about both sides of his mouth
using him in public claiming he's
willing to negotiate and in private
rejecting any compromise team does the
white does the president believe he's
dealing with someone who is negotiating
in good faith the president believes
that negotiations are actually remaining
productive and that's what's important
the conversations that are happening
with his team right this is a team when
it comes to who we're dealing with on
this on the other side of Pennsylvania
right the group of of house house uh
house negotiator and negotiators that is
uh speaker McCarthy's team and so they
remain to be productive we believe that
if it continues to work if they continue
to work in good faith and recognize that
neither side is going to get what they
want we can get this done we can get
this done he is negotiating that's
that's that's been our our experience as
we're dealing with their negotiators and
that's what we're saying if it keeps
going in good faith then we can get to
an agreement here that is bipartisan and
that will get out of the house and get
out of the Senate if necessary is the
president willing to sign a temporary
extension of the deadline in order to
get this done look just not going to get
into any short-term or temporary uh
pieces of legislation what we're trying
to get to is something that has been
done 78 times since 1960 has raised the
debt limit that's something that
Congress has done and uh you know we're
we're we're we're talking about when
you're talking about what's happening
what this manufactured crisis this will
be the first time the first time that we
could potentially uh default and we
should not be doing that this is not
something that this nation is known for
you heard the president say over and
over again we are not a deadbeat Nation
look we're going to let the negotiators
do their job continue to have the
conversation and we believe that there's
a path forward there's not taking a
temporary extension off the table I'm
just saying that that's not the
conversation that we're focused on we're
focused on the conversation that we're
focused on is get dealing uh with a
budget negotiation that that is by
partisan and that is reasonable that's
what's important right now and
continuing to call on Congress to raise
the debt limit or to do their job simple
okay I'm on the debt ceiling is there a
drunk day
is there a is there a drop dead date
where you know after which it becomes
impossible to enact for that let's
legislation that's necessary you know so
do you have to have a deal tonight
tomorrow tomorrow you know it's Friday
enough time to get to that potential
next date no I look I I get this I get
the question uh look
our country has never defaulted on its
debt and it will it will it will never
uh it never will and that's kind of our
Focus right we've never done this and we
will never do this will never happen
right that's the way we see this uh and
um
you know that's going to be our Focus
that's
the answer that I have for you on that
piece word about contingency planning in
terms of
um you know special mentors the treasury
is taking extraordinary Extraordinary
Measures there are additional novel
approaches inscribed by various think
tanks or economists or experts would the
president prefer some
you know extra or additional
Extraordinary Measures to having to
invoke the 14th Amendment
so the as it relates to the 14th
Amendment the president has been very
clear that is just not the answer here
the answer here is for Congress to do
its job like they did so many times 78
times since 1960. that's the answer as
it relates to the X date itself that's
something that the treasury Department
will do that's clearly on their watch
that is something that they will focus
on and so I'm just going to leave it to
the secretary I believe she did an
interview earlier this morning and so I
would refer you to uh to the the
treasury Department on this particular
question typically on Amanda Gorman's
questions being banned in Florida
Elementary School do you have a comment
on that move sure
um so look the president was proud to
have Miss Gorman the youngest inaugural
poet speak at his inauguration as you
all know just a little two over over two
years ago as Ms Gorman said herself the
poem the hill we climb time was written
so that all young people would see
themselves in a historical moment and
the president his administration
certainly stand with her as he was again
very proud to have her at his
inauguration Banning books is censorship
period that's what that is when you ban
a book you are censoring it is uh it
limits American Freedom Americans
freedom and we should all stand against
that type of that type of act when it
comes to Banning on books
yesterday you said that everyone is
working in good faith and you said um
today's briefing that the house speaker
is working a good thing we spoke to the
hostage taking and seeing the white part
out loud now uh do you think that other
Congressional Republicans are working
good faith and what do you say to
Congressional Democrats who feel cut out
of the process and feel like Republican
control of an area so look I can't speak
to other Republicans they can speak for
themselves you can see their quotes and
what they have said and you've all have
been certainly reported reporting that
so I will leave I'll leave their words
I'll let their words speak for
themselves I'll leave that there
look as it relates to other Democrats
look the president is fighting to
protect clean energy manufacturing he's
fighting to protect student debt relief
and to lower costs for prescription
drugs and to save the government money
that is what he is fighting for he's
fighting against proposals that take
away people's health care and push
people into poverty and so the president
has been very clear on that he'll
continue to do that but it is important
to have these types of budget
negotiations it is important in those
budget negotiations to again make sure
that we have a bipartisan reasonable
budget agreement that that both
Democrats and Republicans can support in
the house in the Senate so that it's
going to be the president's Focus and on
the U-Haul truck uh you said yesterday
that the president had been briefed on
that
um has the president been briefed since
or has the White House found any more
about the suspect's alleged interest in
Nazis and Hitler so look I don't have
anything more to share the president
certainly has been kept up to date uh as
I said yesterday morning he was briefed
he was giving a given a briefing from
Secret Service and also the Park police
of what they know so far he was relieved
to see to hear that no no one was hurt
that night and he was very complimentary
and grateful to the agents and law
enforcement officers who quickly who
quickly responded and so anything else
any details or information about the
particular individual I would have to
refer you to the U.S Secret Service I
just don't have anything in more details
to share good Karen thanks um speaker
McCarthy continues to criticize the
president for not meeting with him for
97 days to talk about these issues
given how close we are to this June 1st
deadline with no deal at this point does
the president have any regret for not
engaging with McCarthy over that time
we've been very clear Karen I appreciate
the question and I I know what the
speaker has been saying but we have also
been very clear for the past several
months of where we are and what's at
stake and how important it is for
Congress to do their job to do their job
their constitutional Duty we've been
very clear for months and months uh and
uh and look the president put his budget
out on March 9th he laid out in a very
clear way on how he sees his values
right we talked about values here in
this in the president's quote about that
and how he sees the economy moving
forward to to help the American people
we put that out on March 9th for not
just some Americans to see but for uh
for certainly for house republicans in
Congress to see and so they put out
their budget or pass their budget on
April 26th and you know a few days after
that the president started the budget
negotiations and that's what he laid out
that's what he said he was going to do
put out his budget ask the House
Republicans to put their budget they
didn't pass it until April 26th after
that he we started the budget
negotiations and so again been very
clear about this and at the same time
holding the line and saying how
important it is for Congress to do their
jobs to do their constitutional Duty
got it will the president commit to
staying in D.C until they reach an
agreement or will he travel over the
holiday weekend so look the president
will be will be
um will be wherever he needs to be to
secure reasonable bipartisan deal to
prevent the economic uh catastrophe that
Republicans are threatening this uh this
manufactured crisis and so uh that is
what he's going to do he'll do that
wherever he needs to be I'll note a
couple of things on his schedule so you
all are aware I think you all are
tracking this he will be participating
in a wreath-laying ceremony and
delivering the Memorial Day address at
Arlington National Cemetery that's what
he'll be doing on Monday and Memorial
Day as always he will receive regular
updates from his staff and keep in touch
with members of Congress and he is a
president wherever he needs to be and
that's what you're going to see from
this president
on the Federal Trade Commission
investigate
formula manufact makers colluded on bids
for State contracts is there any concern
about the stability of the formula so I
don't have any comment to make at this
time so I'll just leave that there
a couple quick questions I'll leave some
of the other questions related potential
for default to others but there is a new
covid wave in China right now that's
getting a lot of attention how closely
is the U.S tracking this new wave and is
there any conversation right now about
potential travel restrictions or would
that not be necessary given the US has
already experienced this very entity so
look uh I'll do your last question first
uh where there's no changes of travel
that I will be announcing from here
don't have any any conversations to
speak from to speak of at this time of
course we're always monitoring that's
something that we do when when the when
things like this occur but just don't
have any update for you at this time you
always feel like it's getting accurate
information as it relates to this
coveted wave from China so look it's not
a conversation that I've had with our
teams here so it can't comment give an
official comment on that but certainly
this is something that we continue to
monitor I just don't have anything to
preview or to announce at this time and
within the last hour we learned that
Tina Turner passed away she was 83 I
didn't clearly a surprise to you I
didn't know the White House had any
heads up or if the president had any
comment but I'll give you time to so
look that is the first time I'm hearing
that that is incredibly sad news uh Tina
Turner was an icon a music icon who had
many stages and many amazing moments in
her career very sad to hear the news I
was a huge fan of Tina Turner as you can
see from my my reaction that is the
first that I'm hearing of it and it is a
massive loss massive loss to the
communities that that loved her and
certainly to the music industry and her
music will live will continue to live on
very sad news our hearts go out to her
family and her friends on on her on
their loss
okay I'll go to back ahead Ed thanks
great um so on the debt ceiling uh you
used words like catastrophic and and
devastating today but the president
again is going to Camp David this
weekend and then going to Delaware if
this situation is so dire then why why
is the president well I already answered
that question so you have another one I
literally just answered that question he
came back from Japan
any other questions no that's it okay
great keep going go ahead so it's the
last time that uh has the president and
the speaker spoken since Monday and if
not when are they expected to maybe
speak and engage one-on-one again so
don't have a any conversation to preview
at this time look the president and the
speaker will speak when when the time is
right when the time is necessary to do
that we are giving I've said this
moments ago we're going to give the
negotiators some time to have a
conversation to continue to negotiate we
believe the talks are moving in a
productive way and so I'll leave it
there what is that time I mean is there
sort of a specific sort of narrowing
that has to happen there's no timeline
to throw at you or to lay out to you I'm
just saying that it's been productive
they're here meeting right now they
start around noon today we are hosting
as you know the negotiations today at
the EOB at the office of uh at the OMB
offices and so we'll leave it there
continue to give in the space go ahead
Owen way in the back great thank you
good afternoon if you're doing uh two
separate questions for you one on
Senator tubbardville if he continues to
prevent or hold up Pentagon promotions
he says the dod's new abortion policy is
illegal and he says taxpayer dollars
should not be funding abortions and he's
got a lot of support there's a petition
going around right now supporting his
stance what does the White House say to
Americans who agree I believe this I'll
speak to the senator tuberville is he's
threatening right our national security
with uh his political gamemanship that's
what we're seeing from the senator and
risking our military Readiness by
depriving armed forces of leadership and
harming military families that is what's
currently happening that is what uh is
the senator is is threatening here so we
urge him we urge him to drop his holes
on uh that he has currently on DOD
nominees immediately and that's what
you'll hear from us and a super story
here and this is one that's really
caught the eye of a lot of Catholics and
Christians it's and frankly they're
they're hurt by this the the LA Dodgers
are honoring a group called The Sisters
of Perpetual Indulgence during a pride
night game next spot the Archdiocese of
La Catholic leaders there say the group
mocks the Catholic faith and women
religious who serve the poor and sick
and is asking all Catholics to stand
against bigotry and hate in any form
the president is Catholic we all know
what is his reaction look I appreciate
the question Owen I'm just not going to
get into the middle of uh of uh who a
sports team is going to honor or should
honor or should not honor that's just
not something that I'm going to get in
the middle of it has made it a you know
very it's very important in religious
freedom he's issues statements on it in
the past saying all people of all
religions should be treated with equal
dignity and respect I know I know you
you know you said you just said there
you kind of want to stay out of it but
isn't this a prime example of something
like that I'm just not going to get in
the middle of who a sports team decides
to honor or not honor that is not just
not going to get in the middle of that
but appreciate the question go ahead
Jackie
one off topic first what do you all make
of Hillary Clinton defending Dianne
Feinstein over questions about her age
but not defending President Biden uh the
same questions so I have not heard these
comments so I can't speak to it moving
on CNN poll shows 60 of Americans are
looking for or would support cuts to
spending along with uh raising the debt
limit have you seen that polling and
what do you make of that so look this is
what I believe Americans understand they
understand that uh they want to make
sure that the government that we are
working for them right we're working on
making sure that millions of jobs don't
get lost that would protect their
retirement accounts that we make sure
that we don't lose the gains that we've
made in the last two years as far as
manufacturing jobs so as far as seeing
uh unemployment at its lowest rate 3.4
percent creating 12.7 million jobs those
are the gains that we've made and we
understand that that the Americans
understand that wholeheartedly look this
is a president who has not taken a back
seat when it comes to to uh deficit
reduction 1.7 trillion dollars that he's
been able to cut the deficit by in the
first two years that is a historic
record you put that on top of the three
trillion dollar over the last 10 years
in that in that budget that he put out
on March 9th this is a president who
understands how important it is to cut
spending that's why he also talked about
wasteful spending right that we're
seeing those subsidies that we are
seeing that big oil and big farmer get
and making sure that we get rid of those
subsidies and so he understands what the
American people are looking for they
made that very clear they've made that
very clear in the last election and so
that's what the president's going to
continue to focus on
he started reaching out to federal
agencies to see if they can slide any
payments in early June which would
effectively allow Charter secretary to
push back the X date by more time has
the White House at all been coordinating
with treasury on that is that something
the White House would want to see that
date move we're not coordinating with
that is there for their their decision
to make
Kevin McCarthy's had dozens of gaggle
press conferences about this is that at
all instructive to the president who has
been somewhat media shy in terms of
controlling the narrative here around
this I will uh I feel strongly by saying
this the president is certainly not
media shy uh he would disagree with that
uh that characterization of him he has
been talking about he talked he spoke to
this on Monday he spoke to this on
Sunday when he uh when when he was in
Japan and the president has been very
clear where he stands on what Congress
should be doing which is dealing with
the debt limit something that is their
constitutional Duty he's been very clear
by speaking through his budget that he
put out on March 9th on what he sees the
value of this country how he sees moving
forward with the economy and economy
that he helped put back on his feet by
the successes that we have seen as far
as 12.7 12.7 million jobs low
unemployment rate at 3.4 percent
manufacturing boom and that's all
happened under this President because
because of the economic policy that he's
had folks I will see you tomorrow thank
you so much